my dad was so unbelievably supportive of
my mom my mom sat at the table for every
decision she decided to start an acting
school at one point they sat at the
table they figured out how to make it
work he was like you know let's do this
let's it was he was he didn't run the
house he was a strong force in the house
and on many issues he would say this is
what i think is right she had a seat at
the table for everything and that's how
he wanted it it made for a marriage that
has lasted oh my gosh guys how long are
you married 50 years more you know
they've had their ups and downs it's a
very admirable structure what i learned
from that
was that marriage can be a partnership
can be a give and take and you're gonna
get loud on some stuff and he's gonna
get loud on some stuff but ultimately if
you can find a way to have a situation
where you both sit at the table and make
those decisions together you are in a
win structure no matter what it doesn't
make one person weaker or one person
stronger on everything but it may make
one person weaker or stronger on this or
that and if you can find that right
blend
you're golden